good morning John I've been spending a
lot of time going through the archives
of the vlog with this channels as we're
doing our this day and vlogbrothers
things like in the description to that
if you're curious I'm talking about I
notice that the vast majority of
question Tuesday videos they go to you
John and while this makes a certain
amount of sense because you make videos
on Tuesdays I think it's a little bit
unfair today is question Tuesday on a
Friday I asked people on YouTube and
Facebook and Twitter to ask me hard
questions and here's the ones I got are
you going to answer this question first
yeah that was pretty easy actually what
is the new Republican health care plan
all about this this is a hard one
because there isn't a new Republican
health care plan they just want to keep
all the good parts of Obamacare but make
it cost less by waving their hands of
rain but if you want to get a little bit
less of a partisan hot take on this one
healthcare triage has an amazing and
in-depth video on that he's flying to
space the fastest way for Superman to
fly you know I don't know too much about
the physics of how Superman supposed to
work so if like if air resistance is a
really big deal for Superman
then maybe my feeling is the air
resistance probably shouldn't matter to
Superman too much it's not he's going to
get too hot he seems pretty impervious
probably no it's got to take longer but
the further your radius is the longer
your circumference is that's that's how
circles work but I am NOT Superman's
keeper he can do it however he wants to
do it how do you properly pronounce this
I'm not gonna lie to you I don't know
how to pronounce anything every time I
get a little bit confused I just open up
this app how J say it's just a man who
happens to have said like every word so
what I mean what do you want Jay to say
sorry Jay you're my whole world thank
you for doing you think that great work
and people come to VidCon to they
typically rent a car I don't know if
they do but they shouldn't because
parking in Los Angeles is terrible and
so is driving the cab to your hotel you
can probably walk to the convention
center if you need to you can get an
uber any time how do you eat a pear
without getting pear juice all up and
you know Annalise I'm a huge connoisseur
of pears I love them all sometimes I
want to get it all over sometimes I want
that but if I don't I get out our nice
sharp knife and I just soup right down
and I make a little square of the core
and then I'm like nibble on the core
then just in distributing
it's so good and mess free and clean the
knife and also maybe your plate that you
put them on it such a wonderful
ritual way to spend time the feeling of
the knife going through just like
sooo through that soft soft Bartlet yeah
I may get too excited about pears I just
realized that for the first time would
Bernie have one for this question let's
have a guitar well I don't know and
nobody else does it if you think that
you're sure that you're wrong
it's 2pz to be certain two things that
can be proven so when you feel that way
sing this song how's Dave well if you
talk about the fish
Davis is less less good it could barely
hold up his own string but he's still
floating how many cats is too many cats
well according to my cat two cats would
be too many cats which is terrible for
me because my actual answer is like
maybe eight like cats and pears cat
pineapple apple pear is the S or the C
silent in sin oh that's weird because
scent and scent and scent are all words
right I looked it up of the online
etymology dictionary says that the C and
descent was added in the 17th century
because people felt like it so it's the
C I think that silent can this be the
last question yes I have here with me
additionally a bunch of the prints that
clear Emory made for us to celebrate our
10th year anniversary on YouTube hello
llama yeah I got a Claire to loan me
this so that I could show it off this is
the actual wood block that is put into
the press and these actually degenerate
as they are used and so there's only a
certain amount before they lose their
crispness and you just can't use them
anymore so when you do wood blocks it's
it's definitionally a limited run I love
them they smell good I didn't know that
they would smell good but that's the
thing I'm I just wanted to show you me
holding them in real life so that you
could see the paper and what it looks
like and how big they are and stuff
there's a link in the description if
you're interested in these thanks for
all your questions and John I'll see you
on Tuesday